all right well we're now on problem
number five on page 408 and they have
this little drawing here and it says on
the disk shown above a player spins the
arrow might do my little arrow here this
little little blue arrow
a player spins the arrow twice the
fraction a over b is formed a
over b is formed where a
is the number of the sector where the
arrow stops after the first spin so
there's the first spin
first spin
and b is the number of the sector where
the arrow stops at the second spin
second spin
on every spin each of the numbered
sectors has an equal probability of
being the sector on which the arrow
stops what is the probability that the
fraction a over b is greater than one so
they want to know the probability
that a
over b is greater
than one
well the first thing you need to realize
is this is just you know a random number
generator we could have been the
probability that any number between one
and six is equal so this could just be
you know a roll of a six sided die and
saying well if i roll a six sided die
twice what's the what are the odds
what's the probability that the first
roll is going to be
larger than the second rule right
because in order for this to fraction to
be greater than 1 the numerator has to
be greater than the denominator right or
you could just take
a over b greater than 1 and multiply
both sides by b
and that's the same thing as the
probability
that a
is greater
than b
so what we can do is we can set up a
little table and we could say well
what's the probability of getting each
of these numbers on the first roll and
then given
that probability or or given that you
got you know let's say a two on the
first roll what are the odds that the
second roll is going to be less than the
first row right so let's say or or spin
so let's say spin let's call this
spin
one
two three
four
five
six
and what's the probability of getting
each of
these spins
well the probability uh
on on the first time right probability
of spin so we call that spin one
i'm just making up notation as i go but
hopefully this is makes sense to you so
the probability of getting any one of
these is 1 6 right so we can just say
it's 1 6
1 6
1 6 right they all have an equal
probability
of happening
1 6
right
now
we have to say now given each of these
what's the probability
that your spin two your second spin
is going to be less than right the
second spin has to has to be less than
the first pin
right this is the second spin b
i could actually i could have just
written a here probability of a
probability of a that'll probably make
more sense to you and then we want to
know the probability that the second
spin b is less than a
well if i got a 1
the first time what's the probability
that i get a number less than one out of
these
well
is there any number less than one
there's one but that's not even less
than one that's equal to one so there's
a zero chance
that i get a number less than one right
because there is no number less than 1
that i can get
if i got a 2
well there's only one number less than 1
out of the 6 right that's 1.
so there's a 1 6 chance
a 3 if i got a three on the first bin i
can only get a one or a two on the
second spin right so that's a two sixth
chance
two six
if i got a four i could get a one two or
a three that's a three six i think you
get a you see the pattern here there's a
4 6 chance of getting something less
than 5
and there's a 5 6 chance of getting
something less than 6.
and so
what's the combined probability now
for each of this scenario so what is
what is the probability that i get a one
and then i get something less than one
well you just have to multiply these
probabilities so that's a zero what's
the probability that i get a two and
then something
less than 2 it's 1 6 times 1 6 which is
probability i get a 3 and then something
less than 3
multiply them it's 236
i think you see the pattern here again 3
and then 5 36 5 36 is the probability i
get a 6 and then something less than a
6.
so in general the probability that i get
my my first spin is greater than my
second spin is going to be the sum
of these probabilities right because it
can be any one of these scenarios would
work would would would satisfy a being
greater than b so i just add up these
probabilities so it's let's see it's
the denominator for all of them is 36 i
mean you could say this is zero over 36
right
so it's essentially
over 36
1 plus 2 plus three plus four plus five
now let me add carefully because this is
where i historically mess up my problems
one plus two is three
three plus three
is six
six plus four is ten
ten plus five is fifteen so that equals
over
and that is choice
a
move on to the next problem
image clear image image invert colors
which of the fallacy we're on problem
number six
which of the following tables so it
shows a relationship in which w is
proportional to x
all right so let's let's just write them
all out so choice a
so if we have w
x
so they have
4.
3 5. so w is proportional to x
well that also means that x is going to
be proportional to w right
so in this case
x is three times so you know here we
have times three
is equal to three here we have times two
and here we have you know times five
thirds so we're multiplying by a
different factor every time so w is not
proportional to x and x is not
proportional to w
i'm just trying to figure out what do i
have to multiply w by to get x or what
do i have to multiply x by to get w and
they all have to be the same in order
for them
these two variables to be proportional
so choice a is not right
choice b
w
x
9. so i multiplied well let's see what
i'm doing 3 9 4
5 25. it looks like in every scenario
here we squared w to get x or w is the
square root of x but they're not
proportional because here we multiplied
by three
here we multiplied by four and here we
multiplied by five so once again it's
not going to be choice b
c i will change colors for variety
let me change this brown
c
w
x
10. so i multiplied by 2
right this is what i'm multiplying by
it's not 10 times 2.
6 to 18
6 to 18 i multiplied by 3. i already
know this is wrong right i multiplied by
two different factors it's not choice c
choice
d
w they probably did one of the later
choices just to make sure we do a lot of
work
choice d is 7
to 21 i multiplied by 3 to do that
to 24
times 3 looks good so far
9 to 27
multiplied by 3. so in every case i
multiplied by the same factor so w is
proportional to x or proportionate to x
and x is proportionate to w so d
is our choice
i will see you in the next video and we
don't have to worry about e because we
know that d is our choice i'll see you
soon